check out the line
an increasingly familiar scene
stretching up the east coast of the
united states
long lines of cars waiting to get fuel
as more and more stations say
there's none to sell it's just one more
thing that takes us into
major stress the problem is a major
pipeline that provides nearly half of
all gas diesel and jet fuel to the east
coast
it's been turned off targeted by what
the federal government says are russian
hackers believed to be based in eastern
europe
although a kremlin spokesman is denying
all of the allegations
the hackers labeled darkseid allegedly
penetrated the network of colonial
pipeline last friday
holding the private firm's information
hostage for payment
the company said they shut the pipeline
down to stem the damage
the federal government has temporarily
removed restrictions on transporting
fuel by other means
and the governor of north carolina did
as well declaring a state of emergency
and airline groups are worried it could
have an impact on flights
so far two flights have had to be
rescheduled to add fueling stops
the biden administration says it's been
working to get the oil flowing again
by close of business tomorrow colonial
will be
in a position to make the full restart
decision but even after that decision
is made it will take a few days to ramp
up
operations this pipeline has never been
shut down before
to add to the problem panic buying
analysts saw a 40 percent jump in demand
on monday and experts say even if the
pipeline is back up by this weekend
problems could continue for a few weeks
although the gasoline is transmitted by
the pipeline
it still has to be transmitted or
transferred by
trucks in other words we're already
having a tank wagon
driver shortage in this country because
of the pandemic
remember there are 30 percent
fewer drivers today than there were in
2019
it's all pushing up the price for gas
now at a six-year high
a potential unexpected bump in the road
for an economy that was just starting to
take off
patty culhane al jazeera washington